[Music]
hallo YouTube just love us my friends
this is grunge in here
welcome to the 16th episode of my chest
trap series in this episode I'm going to
show you Fisher's wonderful trap in the
modern Bernoulli defense from the black
perspective the good point I like about
this trapeze
even though Fisher has played this game
in the year 1970 and soon after that
this trap has been published in many
books and articles time to time many
high ranked opponent are falling into
this trap so if you are a modern biruni
player then you should certainly watch
out for this trap in your own tournament
games the opening arises after the
following model d4 Knight to f6 c4 c5
now wide grab the space on the Queen
side with d5 and accordingly black
challenge the white center with a6 after
Knight to c3 pawn captures pawn captures
and the move d6 yes indeed Black has
created of weakness on the d6 square but
in return he get tremendous tactical and
the sharp activity the Fischer game
continue from here onwards with a random
order so that's why just for your
understanding I have picked the most
accurate and most obvious choice from
the white which leads to the same trappy
position why place efore consolidating
his extra space and black plays g6 so
his idea is very obvious he wants to
play Bishop to g7 and put this bishop on
this long diagonal where it can create
some nice attacking chances white
continue with Knight to f3 and now the
obvious move from the both the side
developing the King side bishop and then
castling on the King side so this is
known as a classical variation of the
modern bernoulli okay black continued
with a 6 so if allowed then black will
certainly play B Phi and
more space on the queenside so
accordingly why it needs to stop it with
the MU a for now just like other d4
openings this light square bishop is a
problematic piece in the black cam so
that's why it's very obvious that black
needs to play Bishop to g4 and if
allowed they're exchanging this bishop
with white strong knight or sometimes
even light square bishop of the white
itself now as per the theory the most
obvious choice of the white is Bishop to
f4 and this move is logical as well
white simple idea is to pressurize the
d6 square as quickly as possible and one
good way to achieve this is to play
Knight to d2 Knight to c4 and put more
pressure on the t6 square here the main
continuation from the black side is to
play Bishop captures f3 but at this
position Fischer plays a very tricky
move rook to e8 which create a deadly
trap now if you are playing this
variation from the white perspective you
my recommendation is you should play
either Knight to d2 or Queen to c2 which
completely avoid this trap but as it
happened the most natural looking move
in this position is ash tree which
straightaway leads to our famous trap
when I check this position in online
database I found out that so far h3 has
been played in 22 games and some of the
games are very recent and you can see
the result over here they are tremendous
for the black if you carefully look at
this position as tree looks the more
nature reply because once the black grew
up his dark square bishop then with the
bishop pair and the space in the center
white always get slight advantageous
position and yes indeed it's true
except there is one problem that Fischer
has unleash one of his pet trapping line
before I move on I like you to pause
this video and find out as a black
how you going to continue from here
onwards well I hope you find this
amazing blow dam so suddenly from
nowhere black is a clear bond up and
even though his LightSquared bishop is
hanging white cannot even touch it now
in the game fishers up won and played
Knight captures efore and after rook
captures efore he was clearly upon down
and later on indeed lost the game but we
should obviously need to see what
happens if you open and capture this
bishop after all it's a free piece and
why it doesn't have any major problems
well we reach to the second critical
position of this trap can you identify
blacks next dazzling reply well I hope
you do and find out this second
important blow boom so once again black
regain his piece with extra pawn and if
white foolishly take this bishop then
there comes Knight capture c3 attacking
Queen as well as double attack on the e2
which cannot be prevented so the sample
line can run like this Queen to d2
Knight captures e to check King to h1
and after Knight captures f4 and Queen
captures f4 with 13 moves in the opening
black emerged with a two-point advantage
and with an accurate play this is just
required a technical performance so this
is a wonderful trap exists in the
classical variation of the modern benoni
defense which you should always keep in
mind well thank you for watching this
video feel free to like subscribe and
comment on my video and I'll meet you in
my next episode very soon bye and take
care